انه الوجه الجديد للجيش الاوكراني
الكساندر سسكي اصبح قائدا للقوات المسلحه
بعد تعيين اصدره الرئيس فلاديمير زيلينسكي
في ال8 من عمره هذا العسكري كان قائدا
للقوات البريه الاوكرانيه من بين انجازاته
العسكريه الهجوم المضاد في خاركيف في
سبتمبر
2022 بالنسبه للرئيس الاوكراني يعد هذا
التغيير
ضروره قررت اليوم تجديد قياده القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه الامر لا يتعلق
بالالقاب ولا يتعلق بالسياسه انه يتعلق
بنظام جيشنا وادارته وكسب قده هذه الحرب
للخبره القتاليه يجب على كل جندي وكل رقيب
وكل ضابط ينزل الى الجبهه ان يكون متمكنا
من اتخاذ القرار
الصحيح انا ممتن للجنرال ف زوجني على
سنتين من الحرب انا ممتن لكل انتصار
حققناه معا فاليري زوجني كان احد وجوه
المقاومه الاوكرانيه في وجه الغزو الروسي
في الخمسينيات من عمره يشغل منصبه منذ
تموز يوليو
2021 لكن خلال الاشهر الاخيره تدهورت
العلاقه مع الرئيس بسبب فشل هجوم الصيف
الذي كان يهدف الى تحرير الاراضي
المحتله بالاضافه الى تصريحاته في نوفمبر
الماضي عندما اعلن ان الحرب وصلت الى طريق
مسدود الرئيس الاوكراني قال انه يريد
ابقاء فاليري زوجني في فريقه
فعلى الارض بعد ما يقرب عامين من القتال
بدات ذخيره الجيش الاوكراني في النفاد
ذخيره ضروريه لمقاومه الهجمات
الروسيه